(piano music)
- In the Dominican Republic,
having kinky or coarse hair
is perceived as something
that's unclean, unkempt.
Something that is simply not beautiful.
The salon really cares about
the way that curly hair
is perceived in society.
And we want to be a part
of that change, fully.
In 2014, we were trying
to go into this bar, and
the bouncer said, to my face,
you can't come in, because of your hair.
This hair has done nothing to no one.
This hair is part of who I am.
Why should I put this hair away?
I run as Miss Rizos,
which means Miss Curls in English.
And I am the owner of Miss Rizos Salon
in the Dominican Republic.
So what's goin' on?
We offer all different types of services
specifically for naturally
curly Afro-textured hair.
In 2010, I remember
just straightening the
heck out of my hair.
As my curly hair would grow in,
I would touch my hair,
feel the curl patterns
and say, like, what if all of my
hair would feel this way?
And that's when I decided that
it was time to look in the mirror
and to love myself fully.
Some of the things I would hear back then
is, "Did you forget your comb at home?"
"Did you put your fingers on a socket?"
I mean, all sorts of really mean things.
But I had all these women just stop me
and ask me how to curl it,
how'd I do it, where'd I cut it.
There was this huge thirst, hunger,
for a space where women
would be validated.
And then that led to the
space that I'm in now.
It's been the most amazing
activism I've done all my life.
To think that with a
brush, a pick, or a comb
I can empower someone.
(soft music)
(electronic music)